but along this time I don't like writing
business plans here's why because every
time it came time to write a business
plan it was almost as if my
schoolteacher from junior high school
would say parents should go to your
homework write up a business plan and
I'm sitting here saying wait a minute
first of all I don't know how to write a
business plan secondly I don't think it
works I don't think it's effective I
don't think this thing is gonna work
until I realized how to write up a
business plan that worked for me and
from there on I cannot wait to write up
my business plan for the following year
so today we're going to talk about two
different types of business plans one
which is dissecting and just spending
six seven nine eight hours getting every
single detail of your business plan in
place that you read once a month then
from there gathering all the information
and taking all the simple things the
clear things that you need and creating
a one-page business plan and as someone
you look at multiple times per day so
we're going to cover those two things
today now prior to writing up a business
plan for 2017 let me tell you what's
even more important tithing a bit some
time for 2017 many times we will go
through a past relationship and and the
relationship didn't work and some of us
guys you know we can't wait to just say
you know what she didn't work and we
move on and we go to bar and meter
Neutron we move on then that girl
doesn't work and then we are next one
then this one doesn't work in the next
one then this one for years goes by and
we say wait a minute how come I don't
have a steady relationally things are
working out well because every single
time one of them didn't work you didn't
ask yourself what will you have done
differently what could you have done
differently what can you change about
the next one is there a trend that you
keep picking up on that you know it's
not effective and it's not working for
you we don't do this the same exact way
why most people who write business plans
all they're thinking about is the next
year while the most important year do
the most data for you is a year that
just passed you by in order to predict
the future you get a study history this
is history 2016 what happened in 2016
for you what went right and if you had a
bad 2016 I gauge my year based on what
percentage of my goals that I wrote down
on a sheet of paper become a reality if
less than 50% of my goals become a
reality tells me something here's what
it tells me it tells me one idea
get the best effort or urgency and
number two I don't have the best
strategy in place so it's effort or
strategy and by the way most of the time
it's number one effort some time is
strategy a lot of time people so we
don't send the market was bad and it was
this great 1% of the time you're
forgiven for that 99% of the time I want
to know what I can control and I can
control most of it so we look at the
past year and when I look at my past
year the way I do business plan a lot of
times I used to just look at my business
like it's only business I'm gonna look
at because this is the only thing that
matters
yes that sounds kind of great in a class
that business Wharton School or Harvard
but in life everything's kind of
connected so you know imagine trying to
grow your business while you have a
relationship that's just day and night
you're arguing with your girlfriend it's
tough to drive your business if all you
do is argue all day on text so imagine
you're about to get into a sales
presentation and your grow on a new game
to text fight now I try to go into and
do the presentation for sell that's
going to make you 20 grand properly now
so this is what we do if you have any
problems they don't want do business
with because they feel something's wrong
with you and it's their relationship so
I started looking at my business with
everything that's connected to the
business meaning personal development
this is business this is personal life
my financial issues makes me have a bad
business because I stress out if they
don't have my finances in order my
personal family life you know kids if
you have kids girlfriend boyfriend
husband wife mom dads sibling that
affects business if that's not steady
health you gain 40 pounds all of a
sudden your energy is lower you get
tired earlier you you know you have
certain pain that you know throbbing or
certain things that's affecting this
right you're getting a lot of headaches
and you don't really know where the
headaches are coming from maybe you need
glasses hello PBD I went last week
doctor says I need glasses and I'm
getting glasses so you're going to start
seeing me doing episodes with glasses
which I'm sure the first few episodes
going to be hilarious stay tuned my
glass is officially ready today I
thought I'll go pick them up sometime
later on today spiritual for some of you
guys that are very spiritual is that
connected to your business right so 2016
gauge every one of them how'd you do in
every one of them and this is how you do
it good bad ugly
it was good about your financial a 2016
what was good about it what was bad
about it what was ugly about it what
would you have done differently did you
work hard in 2016 what are some details
you can gather about every one of these
things a relationship didn't work why
not what was good about it what didn't
work what part of it was what I was on
you they could control and change now
I'm not talking about getting emotional
and putting I want to know what love is
or h-town knocking you know some and
then texting her back and saying babe I
miss you so much I wish not talking
about you reminiscing going back that
I'm just saying what was different about
it what can we do different with health
good bad ugly I ate too much man I just
start eating so much bread I hate so
much sweets why am i might just I became
lethargic I only worked out two times a
week at best
I don't even walk in and where I used to
walk I'm not doing it anymore why not
right spiritual business personal
development so then as you're going into
this and you're dissecting everything
about your business for that the
following gear now you're looking at 17
let's just say you found all your
mistakes all the mistakes you made you
said you were going to give up some
things and sacrifice you didn't you
still watch a lot of TV you said you
wouldn't give up certain things to it
you didn't you still watch these are
trends this is what you need this is all
the details you need this is what's
going to help you have a great seventeen
this is the truth this thing's this
hurts this sucks this is not fun but if
you can get through this heavens around
the corner for you in business there's a
heaven for business it's around the
corner but you got to go through hell
first I'm telling you right now you got
to go through hell first so that part's
first now let's just say you went
through this now you want to put a
business over here great for each of
these categories now for 2017 you've got
to start writing things down for
instance financially in 2017 when it
comes unto my finances I'm going to
start saving $3,000 a month
hypothetically I'm throwing a number out
there you know my might one of my things
I want to do in financially in 2017 I
want to say $50,000 I don't save
$100,000 I'm gonna say $10,000 I wanna
save a million now certainly whatever
the number is I want to do that great I
want to pick up these habits great when
it comes down to my family I want to
look for a girlfriend I want to find
somebody steady I want to look for a
boyfriend
I remember in oh wait oh wait oh no oh
six oh seven when I assess my 2006
and I was going into seven I had to ask
a very weird question for myself here's
what's the question do I even want to
get married I saw a bunch of my friends
getting married they were happy some of
them were miserable I saw these stories
about oh you don't want to have kids man
let me tell you one thing about kids
you're gonna step I wish they would've
tell me bro all this stuff about kids
are great people do it because
everyone's doing it that and I just
study dude do I want to have kids
do I wanna have a family then I made a
decision I do want to have kids I do
want to have a family I'm the only bit
David left in our lineage that can
continue the family I do want to have a
family and I do want to continue this
but here's the next part I have no clue
exactly what I'm looking for so I went
and studied I read a book 101 questions
to ask before you get engaged by Norman
right and I went through all these 101
questions I got very clear on what I
wanted I took those book I was dating
four girls at that time I had each of
them read the book came back three off
one made sense those three are happily
married all of them they're happily
married they all have great marriages
they're all good where they're at but
they just wasn't a fit for each other
and I moved on and I found my wife and
we're married we have three kids and
we're still happy as of today be married
for seven and a half years right but I
had to figure out what I want to do man
find my family I can't just say let's go
17 no clarity you want clarity what do
you want clarity what are you looking
for right so family health spiritual
personal depth what needs to change
once you figure that part out like let's
just say in business and business you
may say what do I need in business I
need better systems great who do I need
I need seven great salespeople this year
I need one great Sales Leader and I need
two phenomenal assistants and I need one
operations person great write it down
how much do you need this year to expand
your business I need to make around a
million dollars this year okay great
write it down that's what you need to
make great then how are you going to
make a million dollars then you go break
that down then that's the part when you
write a long business plan so you need
to create a mathematical formula Phi 2x
times y plus Z I will make a million
dollar so then give yourself a formula
to hit that number that's the long
business plan long business plan that
you write on shows you so your goals are
here how to get it is in a deep written
business plan that you have right once
you've done that once you have done that
and you've written the detailed business
plan then on one sheet of paper one
sheet of paper
you'll laminate the front on one sheet
of paper you're right down 2017 you can
put the title whatever you want the year
of dot dot dot give it a title every
year is a new campaign
what is 2017 no for you what is your
life 2070 like right here one of my
favorite ones is 2070 year of recreating
myself the year of recreating myself I
think that's a phenomenal way to start
up or anybody but yours may be in Europe
explosion the Europe growth the Europe
expansion the Europe you know whatever
it is you figure out a word but you're
you're you need to give it a title
what is 2017 going to represent you this
gets a lot more fun as you keep
continuing and doing it 2017 to Europe
dot dot great then on one sheet of paper
all of these four six brackets that you
have each one of them have two things
written on them obviously when it's a
sheet of paper it's more room I'm just
writing it on the board here at on one
side it's three new habits you want to
instill in this part of your life three
new habits for instance financial let me
give you an idea in Oh two I created the
habit of running my credit score every
single month once a month I remember
even on what day it was it was a 19th
every month I ran my report that's a new
habit second I tracked every single one
of my financial accounts on the 19th of
every single month mutual funds stocks
investments bonds artifact whatever I
had every single month was my financial
statement so these are new habits then
the next one is goals habits goals have
its goals three no more than three three
is enough for your brain to remember
this three new habits three new goals
family three new habits you got kids
Sundays I'm going to do that dot that
with my kids great you know you got
family I'm going to visit my parents
once a month they live somewhere else as
two hours away whatever it is too
you habits goals I want to find a steady
boyfriend or girlfriend goals not this
year next - we want to have kids goals I
want to strengthen my relationship with
my father whatever goals goals habits
goals
habits goals same with health habits
workout three times a week habit don't
eat bread all your wrong except for
Sunday's no sweets all year long except
for Sunday's look what happened to your
business to your life health
so that's habits goals goals could be
190 pounds 13 percent body fat
benchpress 300 pounds goals
run a 26-mile marathon okay one of my
friends recently uh where did he run it
George ran a 26.2 mile marathon he ran
it in Bakersfield
right he said he's going to run it he
ran it this is a guy been mentoring for
the last 12 years so he said I'm a
running he ran it it's very strong
mentally so he put goals I want to run a
marathon go run it I'm gonna benchpress
two plates 20 times
go do it that's the goal for each side
personal development I want to read two
books a month four books a month okay I
want to write 350 books this year great
personal development I want to find a
new mentor that's a goal that is exactly
the life I want to have I want to find a
mentor you write it new habits what is a
habit a habit is you know I am
associating myself with people that are
better than me I'm you can figure out
the new habits that you can put in I'm
gonna read 30 minutes a day you have it
I'm gonna have meditation spiritual time
30 minutes every morning whatever it is
for you then business same thing three
three so habits goals habits goals
habits goals habits goals now watch what
happens when it's three habits three
goals you have your detailed business
plan you revisit once a month because
the detailed business plan is going to
show you how to get 290 pounds how to
get to to 12% body fat how to do you
know XYZ amount of revenue this year how
to have $100,000 in savings that's the
hell - this is the goal but your brain
needs to see the numbers and then you
can validate it with the formula that
you've written on a sheet of paper that
could be 10 pages
seven pages but it needs to be in
frontier face so what this one shooter
does for you you're allowed to review it
daily you're able to drive your
initiatives and you riri review review
boom review boom RiRi mine
RiRi my rear Iman RiRi my dreary mind
and it's in your face in your face in
your face in your face in your face how
do you and I learned the same lyrics to
song RiRi Mari Rema Rema Rema how do you
and I know the words too commercial you
know the Dos Equis commercial you know
he saw this that even as enemies put him
down as his emergency phone number
whatever RiRi mine rerun I didn't put it
in our face so many times three remind
and they drove the initiative then they
reviewed let's adjust let's drive the
next initiative RiRi mind we're the
great Dos Equis review same thing you
got to do to your brain and your heart
same thing you got to do okay so once
you do this one pager then you got to
make some sacrifices so what are your
sacrifices what are you going to give up
this year what are you gonna give up in
2017 what are you willing to give up
show TV bar beer drinking alcohol
smoking what are you going to give up
what are you going to give up in 2017
because you know what you need to give
up everyone's got a vice what are you
going to give up in 2017 sleeping in
because that's the effort and the
strategy and the more time you spend on
the strategy the details the better of a
one page you can write the better of a
one page you can write and you remind
yourself the rest is history so you
maybe ask him and I wish I had this
format I got it for you I got it for you
here's what I need you to do I need you
to go to my website Patrick wait David
calm if you're watching this video on
the website go to the bottom we have the
one pager for you the PDF you can
download on exactly how to have your one
page business plan written on a sheet of
paper then you can use yourself and
it'll be a format all you got to do is
print it out
grab it laminate it put it against your
shower wall every morning you wake up
every night you go to sleep look at it
and read it out loud just look at it
look at it look at it look at it review
drive remind every day every day every
day you will be amazed within a week 2
weeks 3 weeks how much of this is
already internalizing you you can't help
yourself I'll be thinking about it and
somehow someway you start hitting it
remember effort strategy we got the
strategy if you put the time here's a
one-pager then it's reminder drive
review and eventually the next year
comes back up 2017 and you're going to
look at your you know last year how this
year went by you're gonna say oh my gosh
I hit eighty percent of my goals this is
so exciting I hit eighty percent of my
goals and by the way people ask me for
book recommendation with this honestly I
will take the best book recommendation I
can give you on this this is this may
sound like I'm self promoting but I
don't think I don't can't can't remember
the last time I self promoted this book
I will tell you though I highly
recommend reading this book I wrote
called 25 loss we're doing the
impossible it's been sold 150,000 copies
translated in five different languages I
think now it's also Mandarin six
different languages that you can find
and one thing about this book 25 loss
we're doing impossible I wrote out
exactly the formula I use to recreate me
so I'm telling you pure experience how
this cat went from being a 1.8 GPA in
high school to somebody no one expected
was going to do anything goes into
military comes out becomes a Salesman at
Bally's and gets into business struggles
for two three years four years trying to
figure this whole thing out then I
recreated myself then the rest was
history this book the first ten laws are
all about how to recreate yourself then
how to identify your cause and how to go
out there and make history so you can
have the link to the book Paul let's
make sure we put the link to the book on
the bottom as well twenty-five laws for
doing the impossible and last but not
least Paul give me what you got there to
your left oh my gosh let's see that
first and I'll given the other one so
this one here poor pillow has done a
very good job for us in 2016 it helped
us hit a goal today we had a young cat
that drove 30 miles from 30 miles away
named Philip came through to just give
us this new pillow and we haven't yet
decided what's going to be the new
pillow we're going to choose a new
pillow this outer pillow goes subscribe
to value Taemin I love this new pillow
Philip you to subscribe to value team
and subscribe to value tainment
it's a cool looking pillow it's one of
the top three right now that we're
looking at if you haven't sent your
pillow if you have not send your pillow
we will be designing for despite
December 31st
on what pillow will be featured in our
videos in 2017 to say subscribe to value
Taemin because our goal in 2017 to get 2
million subs so if you haven't
subscribed please do so Paul give us a
good catch if you got any questions
comments thoughts about this video
comment on the bottom take everybody
bye-bye
[Music]